okay um
welcome to the ddps
seminar everyone before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions if
you have questions you are welcome to
unmute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today it is an honor to host
santi
adebani who is a cto and co-founder of
rocket ml as ctos and he drives the
technology roadmap that includes the
design and development of scientific
machine learning solutions
prior to rocket ml santi worked as a
senior data scientist and ai product
manager at intel
where he led the development of ai
systems for automated data management
for yield enhancements he received a ph
phd
from the university of pennsylvania
where he developed fast algorithms to
solve partial differential equation
constrained optimization problems on
supercomputers with applications in
electrocardiology
today santi will talk about industrial
grade scientific machine learning
challenges and opportunities this is a
very interesting topic
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further due let me pass the
button to santi by asking one random
question
as usual today's question is what is
your favorite things to do other than
your other your job role as a cto
oh uh thanks for inviting me also yeah
my favorite thing uh i play volleyball
uh in my free time and if the weather is
good i go hiking
pacific northwest has beautiful
trails so that's the other thing i do
nice nice well with 100 degree i guess
okay all right stage is yours
thank you
okay hello everyone it's great to be
here uh
so today i'll talk about uh industrial
grade
scientific machine learning and
challenges and opportunities so before i
go in i would like to thank all my
collaborators
from rocket ml uh iowa state university
and nyu
and with the for so
the challenges and opportunities i'm
going to talk about today are about
how do we take scientific machine
learning
that is more in the academic setting
today and how do you make it to good
goodness how do we make it so popular as
machine learning in general and how do
we make it
accessible to a lot more people lot more
organizations so that
we see the real value of saml going into
into industry
so for those of you who have not
heard about this before so this is uh
my talk outline i talk about
introduction tell you what sci ml is and
motivate the problem i'm looking at a
little more
i'll talk about challenges and
opportunities and in specific i'll
discuss about ambiguities scalability
and deployability problems and i
summarize my talk so that's the outline
so saml is scientific machine learning
for short and uh this is the definition
from department of energy in 2019
so the way it's defined is it's a core
component of ai
that can be trained on
scientific data right so that's the
10 000 foot level definition and in
order to uh
simplify it the way we look at it is it
is at the intersection of
uh laws of physics science and machine
learning and and that is the
intersection that we are most interested
in and we were talking about cyan
so from this 10 000 foot level
definition if you want to kind of bring
it down
and look at ciaml through the lens of
data and the lens of amount of
information used
on
one end of the spectrum we have
scientific computing right this is a
traditional way of solving
physics problems
and
or chemistry or any science problems
right for that matter
we have the formulation of the problem
be it pde ode
or any other way of defining in a
scientific manner
and we use traditional methods finite
elements finite differences molecular
dynamics
uh finite volumes so on and so forth and
we solve a given physics problem right
using traditional methods
and on the other end we have a
large-scale machine learning
world that is that is uh that is
exploring that is
you have a lot of data coming from
either simulation a lot of data coming
from
sensors and
we are using all the data where the
physics is implicit
and building these building machine
learning models large scale machine
learning models to
to to explain the physics or to embed
the physics in a model
and there's a lot happening in between
right so that is
you're using the best
um
learning from like from from scientific
computing and you're also using the
learnings from machine learning and this
coupled region is what what we can term
as scientific machine learning where
you're using data as well as the physics
from uh either explicitly or implicitly
and there is a lot of work going on in
this space
be it solving
pdes using neural networks we're solving
inverse problems
and a lot of methods being developed in
the community which has significant
implications for
simulations control design and
and inverse problems
so the value of scientific machine
learning is is very well understood so
that is when we go talk to somebody in
the industry and explain the value of
saml it's very clear that is we are
going to speed up time to solution so
the time to solution for a given problem
can be accelerated by orders of
magnitude is a value proposition that
everyone understands
and that's a baseline that we can think
of when we think of science
and here we i'm giving you two examples
that uh
that were published from from our group
the first one is a is a fluid flow
problem uh where a traditional method
would take around 400 seconds for
simulation and using a cyan l model it
would take around 10 seconds right so
when i'm talking about
the siamel solution i'm primarily
talking about the inference side of
things that is i've already built a
model
and i'm using that model to do inference
same thing with heat transfer so if you
have a steady state heat transfer
problem
you can
solve the problem using a traditional
method which would take a lot of time in
this case i'm talking about
a 5 12 cube problem with millions of
pixels or boxes
and when i try to solve the same using
ml it would take around 20 seconds so
the value proposition for using saml is
is fairly clear and we've been
demonstrating that
but the challenge is
how do we take this from from lab to
bedside right so how do you make
industrial great for
applications that are have high societal
impact and
have very low margin of error and have
to be robust and fall tolerant so how do
we go from
um
having this academic discussions and
having all these publications which are
doing really amazing work and uh take it
from there to actually being used in
say
designing heat exchangers or
or designing
drugs for uh
or designing uh different implants for
in
the medical industry right so what are
these challenges to make siamese more
ubiquitous and how do you make it
accessible to industry
uh and industry researchers is is the
challenge that i'm going to discuss
today
the first challenge that we run into is
ambiguity right so that is
when we're talking about uh traditional
solvers um
the terminology that we use is fairly
clear that is you have certain control
parameters uh be it boundary conditions
initial conditions uh material
properties and you want to solve a pde
so i'm going to discuss
most of the topics in the context of
pdes
because that's one of the major work
that's happening
and within that context the terminology
is control parameters you have a solver
and uh you are predicting certain state
variables right so for example in the
case of uh
poisson problem a steady state heat
equation or conductivity or any a lot of
applications that can be
modeled using a model using this
elliptic equation
one of the use cases is you're changing
the diffusivity or the input material
property in this case
new
and you're trying to predict
a solution which is the output of
this
equation using a solver
so the input output
mechanisms of
of a traditional solver is fairly well
understood and the terminology around
uh solving a pde is also very well
understood
but when we talk about translating this
problem into a deep learning problem
where
there is innovation that is needed
across all stages
it things start becoming a little more
ambiguous and and vague for
communication purposes and this is one
barrier we see for
for a lot more people to start using
xaml and trying to make
uh uh make best use of the all the
innovations are happening right so just
to
make this a little more clear
when we're going from a traditional
problem to a deep learning problem now
we need to think about scientific
machine learning in the context of a
neural network and that is what is the
input data how are we defining the input
data
uh how do we represent that data for
example is it
is it points is it voxels how are we
representing this data
and uh what are the network
architectures used right for example in
in some cases you want to use
a multi-layer perceptron in some case
you want to use cnn's etc etc and
there's a lot of innovation happening
even within the
network architectures and you want to
define the loss functions right so
there's a lot happening within the loss
function space
so a few examples within that is uh when
we talk about network architectures uh
these are some of the work that we do
internally we we try to uh classify
these as
uh point-wise architectures and
full-field architectures right so
uh when we talk about point-wise
architectures the
main problem we are looking at is how do
we map a single point to a single point
right so what that means is you have a
material properties or
certain control parameters where you're
training the network using a single
point in the mesh or single point in the
domain and you're predicting the output
uh so it has its own pros and cons and
from a from a industry point of view
this has implications that is you may be
able to train very fast
but inference would require you to
sample at lot more points
and also the other implications are
you're solving one instance of the pde
uh but you may have to enforce these
boundary conditions uh
explicitly in your loss function so that
those become
some challenges and obviously a lot of
advantages of using point-wise
architectures
and when it comes to full-field
architectures the idea is you can
actually pass in
a full field as your input and get a
full field as your output that is the
input
properties you are passing in are an
entire mesh
or an entire voxel grid in this case and
the output is a solution of that
so in this case the pros are you you can
enforce your boundary conditions
conditions exactly
but training becomes uh expensive but
inference could be much faster because
you've already trained the network
enough with enough samples and you can
also solve a parametric set of pdes and
not just a single pde
to
to be used this for other use cases
and when it comes to loss functions this
loss function that we work
on internally is
can we define the loss function without
using any simulation data right so for
example
when we define a neural network
architecture and try to predict
an output you can either compare that
output with
with an existing simulation data right
that way you can use
the traditional loss functions to
simulate it
or you could use the respective pde and
use that as a residual
to train your network
so in this case one of the things we did
was we write the solution in terms of
the basis functions
and use calorical method to to
multiply the test function with the
solution
and
apply an integral on it to define a loss
function
so what this allows us to do is it
allows us to actually impose boundary
conditions exactly and also use the
literature from finite element methods
to
um
to describe uh convergence criteria
describe error bounds and get good
results
so there's a lot of work going on in
this space but when it when we actually
have to communicate this
with uh with external parties and try to
say
hey what how do we go about
uh using this there are a lot of
questions on what is what is the method
does uh what are the problems we are
solving and how does it compare with
existing solutions
so one opportunity we see here is and
also this is something that we can work
as a community is establishing
a certain ontology
around scientific machine learning and
and here again um
i may be talking about
a specific subset of the problems that
we encounter uh
at rocket ml that is within the partial
differential equivalence space but
siamel itself is a much broader umbrella
with uh
with uncertainty quantification problems
a lot of problems that
we are
not 100 percent aware of and that's
where i think we can also work with the
community in this case the audience here
to grow this language that we are
speaking right so
the language that we speak especially in
the pde space is hey what is the input
data what are you trying to
use as input for your neural network
and in this case
the cases we work with are material
properties boundary conditions geometry
and so on and so forth and if you look
at the counterpart in the machine
learning world
you can think of these as like they're
the language is fairly clear you're
talking about either nlp problems or
image problems or
tabular data so the language there is
fairly clear and we need uh within the
cml community our own way of describing
the problem we are solving
the second thing is uh data
representation which is
uh points voxels graphs is one way of
representing the
data
and uh and each of them have
implications in terms of how we
solve the problem right because points
require different architecture boxes
require different architecture graphs
require different architectures
and how do we represent the network
right so once we have the the data
representation and what we're solving
uh what is the network representation is
it mlp
is it cnns is it graphs and there's a
lot of innovation happening within each
of these network representation and
fourier interval operators are the
popular ones
and how do we
make it clear for somebody looking at
this as a as an innovation
and last but not least the last function
itself right that is
you have data driven methods where you
need simulation data and you have data
free methods which take advantage of the
the pde formulation or the physics
information
um
to
to describe your
losses right and within that you can
have point wise full field fem
fdm and so on and so forth so this is
one challenge i think we have a
communication challenge and ontology
challenge
uh that we can solve by by trying to
come up with certain criteria and the
other thing is benchmarks so we need
these these benchmarks that
um
they're fairly well established in the
milk community but we need these in the
cml community which is what are the
problems you're solving right so are you
solving an ode pde steady state or like
definitely this list is not exhausted
what are the problems you're solving and
uh
and then the data sets right so for
example
uh can we have this uh industry uh
standard data sets on for these
different problems can we have these
geometries boundary conditions initial
conditions that industry at lab
at scale is very interested in to solve
so that any innovation that is happening
in this space is is can be easily taken
by for the real world problems
the the third one is accuracy
performance like how does this new
method or this new
uh technology uh in terms of data
representation or your network or loss
function how does it work
uh and what is the accuracy uh
performance for that new method is
another
uh thing we can work on and the last two
are training performance and inference
performance that is how does it what
does it take to train these models and
uh what does it take to infer right so
these are some of the uh benchmarks that
we can put together
and
um
and encourage
the community to chip in to to
engage in this conversation to
improve these benchmarks and also come
up with new ways of describing the work
the second challenge which we focus
fairly on is the scalability aspects of
it so most of the challenges that we see
uh to for industry option is also about
the scale
uh solving in a in a 2d problem in a
small setting versus solving it at scale
is a whole different challenge so i'll
give you a very detailed example here
and the way we solved it uh at rocket ml
and that can
trigger some conversation so the problem
we were looking at here was solving
an elliptic problem
and in this case we were looking at
training a neural network
where
the input is a diffusivity in this case
the value of new in 3d
and the output of the solution is what
we want to predict using this neural
network
um and it has digital boundary
conditions on on both sides and neumann
on one side
and there is no forcing function
so in order to train this network
especially when you're working with say
using a network like 3d unit in in
middle
uh the challenges we run into our
training these nets on gpus is is
expensive right so gpus have relatively
small memory
and
when we have
large
image volumes because
when we walk talking about scientific
computing problems the the grid
resolution still matters right so you
still need to
have final grid to resolve the physics
and when you have large image volumes
and even for a fixed
network size the peak memory
that you need on a gpu
would exceed right so for example once
we hit a
128 cube we can no longer use certain
teslas
uh and once we hit more than 128 cube we
cannot use um
v 100 and even with the latest ones like
a 100 there is always an upper limit in
terms of how far you can go
and the only way around this is is scale
out right so we need to train on
multiple nodes multiple gpus and and
using a hpc cluster
and once you go to the scale
uh it's no longer just distributed
computing problem that is how do we use
these gpus
[Music]
to uh to for optimal memory consumption
and
uh how do you use the cpus it also
becomes a matter of uh
um uh of uh how do we take advantage of
the parallel file system because we want
to do check pointing in between
and
use the file system for for existing
data and so on and so forth and how do
you manage your uh ethernet bandwidth to
uh communicate between the nodes
etcetera etcetera so it becomes a
distributed computing problem to solve
psi ml at scale
so we tried that right so we basically
said okay the simplest thing we can do
is uh scale it out so let's use more
gpus
and throw more at the problem to see if
we can solve a problem solve this 3d
training problem
and what we concluded was yeah we we put
in more machines and
we were able to train
uh it took us around 34 hours to train
this on eight gpus but
just throwing more gpus at the problem
is too slow and it's not sustainable
so the
uh the challenge we went with like can
we come up with some kind of algorithmic
innovation right so we can always throw
more compute to
solve a problem but that is not
sustainable how do we use algorithmic
innovations so this is where some of the
ideas from
existing solvers right from the
scientific computing world can
potentially be used in
uh in scientific machine learning also
so the the methodology we went after and
and this has been published in last
year's uh supercomputing paper
is using this multi-grid
approach to train networks using
hierarchy of mesh sizes right so for
example
instead of
training this network
at the the finest resolution
can we train the network um
at uh at a fine resolution but don't
train completely
uh use the network weights to train uh
the courser grid uh network and continue
to train that until a point where you
can still resolve physics but it's not
too small
and use those network weights to
iteratively update
your
solution at other grids right
and
bringing some ideas from uh from the
from the scientific computing world and
applying it here
has given us some benefits in terms of
trend so in this case for for a little
more detail here we started off with a
with a depth
unit so what i mean by depth 4 unit is i
have
four
[Music]
layers in the down
stream of the unit and uh and four on
the top including the bottleneck layer
and the first thing we do is basically
take in a
coarser resolution
data set
and
train that coastal resolution data set
on
on this 3d unit
so once we train this and in this case
we don't have to train this
at
for the entire
until convergence we can actually stop
it in between
and once you have that we actually build
a new network right so what i mean by a
new network is
we take in the depth for 4
unit and plug it in as a part of the
network that is
of a bigger size right
and
once you have this you can transfer
these weights to this underlying network
and
do this transfer line right so when i'm
talking about transfer learning here i'm
talking about going from uh
one node right so when i say one node
here it's basically going from
one level to the next level okay
so once you figure out this um this
network transfer in terms of weight
and
uh experiment with
different uh combinations of these uh b
cycle
uh w cycle and f cycle and so on and so
forth you can come up with the the best
combination of uh accuracy and speed up
and uh use it for for training right
because
uh once we start training these models
they can become pretty expensive in
terms of both compute cost as well as uh
as well as
runtime okay
so
what i'm presenting here is basically um
the the results from from that work
right so
uh we still left the
problem with
eight gpus so for example
in this case uh we trained the baseline
with eight nvidia gpus on azure
and for training
a 256 cube resolution problem so in this
case i have
a lot of data which we which we
basically generated synthetically and
used it for training and that took
around uh two thousand minutes right so
the plot you see here is basically
training a 256 cube problem up to
convergence okay so i'm not showing the
entire
x-axis here but to reach certain uh lost
value it took
around 2000 minutes
and
the same problem uh to basically train
using multigrid that is we start off
with a
32 cube
problem
trained it to certain number of epochs
to see
how far we can get the loss value
and then use that network for 64 cube
and
and iteratively
went down the
or increase the resolution right so
what we are presenting here is basically
what does that mean right so for example
when you're
using multigrid using 3264 128 256
for smaller
grid sizes because the network is also
smaller you can train faster so it takes
around 10 minutes to train the the first
branch of this network and then as you
go for larger sizes in this case 64 it
takes 20 and so on and so forth but the
accumulated time it takes overall to
train this is at just around 150 minutes
compared to doing this time below right
so standalone basically trains
uh uh takes a very long time and you can
not only see the value of that and
obviously in terms of the time but also
in terms of cost
so
the
idea of doing things at scale uh also
to become
first-class citizens in the sense
in addition to training or building
these models at small scale
uh doing it last skill is important and
and here if any of the audience working
on any small scale problems and see
potential for this at large scale
we are happy to collaborate with you
and bring in rocket ml's expertise in
hpc
and uh and deep learning to train these
problems faster
and
and these problems can also be solved on
on cpu clusters sometimes right for
example
uh if you want to solve this at uh 512
cube resolution so instead of solving it
256 and you want to scale it out to 512
and this is just doing distributed data
parallel deep learning
even that won't fit into uh it won't fit
in gpu memory and you need you can use
cpus to train these
so in this case what we did was
obviously using doing it at 512 cube
resolution on cpus it's it's not
feasible it takes forever to do that
but you could do this mix and match
right so that is
you can
train your networks all the way to 256
cube on a
on on these gpu clusters and take those
information and take it from
gpus and do few iterations on cpus okay
so
that way you basically can take
advantage of your cpu memory which is
also much larger than the gpu memory and
do not have the implications of slowness
on cpus because they're not built for
this kind of deep learning training
cycles
and
that gives best of both worlds right so
you can you can split from one to the
other
and what we think is
instead of investing in in more
complicated
uh
uh distributed algorithms that may have
may not scale very well
we could come up with this kind of
algorithmic innovations that can help
training
faster but still using the existing
infrastructure
without giving up on the scalability
aspects of it right that is as you
increase the number of machines you want
to you want to reduce your
time to solution
okay
so this is basically uh
the other challenge the channel that is
scalability is one challenge and we have
some ways to solve them
the third uh one is deployability so
this is a problem in
in machine learning in general and it is
a little more acute i think within the
cml community is there is a lot of
ecosystem built in and and there is a
lot of solid solutions out there
uh that have been um
solved for
uh for a long time and their existing
software
so any new system has to work alongside
these existing tools right so it's ideal
scenario
uh
but the the the
the main intent there is there is there
is something already exists either a new
solution works along with it and if you
want to replace it that becomes a fairly
big challenge especially given uh
an existing solution might be working
very well for that matter right
so with that challenge and you bring in
these challenges with machine learning
itself right so machine learning has too
many wheels so
um
this this uh uh
what i'm showing here is applicable even
for any general purpose machine learning
let alone scientific machine learning
there are a lot of things happening when
you go from
prototyping to production right so what
i mean by that is you're starting off
with a with an idea you're saying okay
let me try to solve this
scientific computing problem using
machine learning so you start building a
hypothesis and
uh you start identifying your data sets
and you you do some kind of exploratory
data analysis and start building a model
and within building a model there are
going to be a lot of cycles that is you
have to
work with your
refining the data you need to work with
defining your network architectures
try to apply new methods that are coming
in in the community and come up with a
model that is that is reasonably that is
reasonable right that works well enough
to say okay let me take this and and go
to
production but how does that model
integrate into uh
into an existing system right so how do
my users downstream
who are
familiar with using uh these existing
solvers can they use my new solvers that
is based on
machine learning
so there are these operational
challenges which basically
[Music]
makes it
a makes it a problem for um for anybody
doing a prototyping on
ml
to take it to production right so
actually when i say to production how to
make people actually use these models
that are built
built at scale
and
that might be working fairly well
so a few solvers so the way we are
addressing this is basically build these
iml solvers that are easy to consume
right so
can we make
any of these solvers consumable like can
we make give them something where
you can bring in a geometry or bring in
physics models and try to use these uh
inputs right and whatever the input data
that we're talking about and in for
different domains these inputs might be
different
and can we build these ciamer solvers
that
take in these inputs that the users are
familiar with
and you can actually build a solution or
solve the problem on the fly and give
them a solution right so we need to
think about a different way of
integrating
these latest innovations within the saml
community and trying to make it easy for
others to consume are there any cml
solvers that are readily consumable that
we can put out there
and if you're working on any any
specific problems and you want to
package them as solvers we are happy to
chat with you offline
the the second problem is let's say we
want to uh
have a technology that
where we we are not providing the
solvers but we want to
we want the researchers in an industry
or research and organization to build
these uh models right
so in that case they will need an entire
platform that can
not only
uh work with respect to model discovery
so this is the first box here
is where a siamel researcher would
work on
figuring out okay what is my problem
what is the data i need to work with
uh what is my
scientific problem that i need to
formulate as a an ml problem and use uh
one kind of compute right so in this
case cpu is gpus to
generate the data as well as train
and build a model
and then once the model is built
it is not trivial to
uh
to to deploy it let's say we deploy it
um
that model is only as good as the data
that it saw right so any ml model
doesn't matter whether it is
uh
scientific or otherwise
requires
some kind of monitoring some kind of
retraining some kind of way to say okay
this is no longer working
well for the problem at hand but how do
we
improve it okay
and
and what are the retraining triggers
that we need to look at are all the
[Music]
unknowns at this time and
uh some kind of a platform to
enable this entire pipeline is something
interesting and this is another thing
that we work on which is how do we bring
these scientific computing world and the
machine learning world
together so that
the whoever is trying to build these
models get out get best of both worlds
that is
they can
they can check whether their ml model is
working as well as the traditional
solvers
and
not only that it makes it easy for them
to deploy
so that the end users within the
industry can actually consume and
get
uh get the best value out of all the
innovations that are happening okay
so with that um
40 minutes in um um
uh so simon
to summarize i'm kind of wrapping up
talk and samuel is transforming uh
simulation sciences and has compelling
value proposition for the industry
we can demonstrate that it is energy
efficient obviously once the model is
built
and
we can reduce the time to solution that
is a there are bigger value propositions
for uh
that resonates very well and it has a
relatively lower memory footprint uh
because once you train they have a model
they can take
uh take advantage of it
and the opportunities to accelerate this
transition from traditional to saml a
lot of opportunities here that the
community can work alongside industry
that is establishing
an ontology
and establishing certain benchmarks
bringing in hpc scalable solutions
because scientific computing is a hpc
heavy
uh domain
and
bringing in hp scalable solutions is
very attractive
and
tuned
uh platforms towards more of a
scientific machine learning use cases so
that
we can
deploy the solutions make it real world
and have a real world impact fairly
quickly and make this overall space more
uh accessible and lubricators for
uh more people coming into this industry
okay
so with that
i thank you for your
[Music]
for your time
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk i really enjoyed this
auntie um
very
new perspective from from the
from the cto of who works in the
industry um on the scientific machine
learning
okay let's have a quiet session maybe
you can keep the the slide um of course
you know some of some of the question is
specific to a specific slide so if you
can share that again that would be
wonderful
all right and um
yeah so there are
in in
in chat room um young sue this is pat
why why don't we talk with the start
with a technical question so if there's
time we can come back to the
terminological issues
yeah yeah so we yeah that's what i was
about to suggest uh with that okay pat
thank you so much for
you know stepping up on that
okay so sounds good let's do the
technical question if you have any any
questions um
then please
do so i i do see one technical question
from
george's
he asked how do technologies like
unified shared memory platform for
avoiding the limited gpu memory problem
i guess that's related to your
multi-grid
approach
um to overcome the memory issue
of the training the neural net
yeah i mean so what way we think about
is yes there is a lot of innovation
happening in these spaces right that has
the
there could be more memory available
using
well i'm not familiar with that specific
technology but
there is always more memory needed to
train these networks because the
the network is getting bigger or the
problem resolution is getting bigger so
we will always hit a limit in terms of
how much you can use it's a typical hpc
problem
and
uh if there is a new technology i'd say
this this approach still is applicable
for
uh
for using more memory and maybe solve
bigger problems
okay related to that um
how diverse
you know
the different problem have you tried
this multi-grid training um to
santi um
i mean the examples you have shown
obviously that's one particular problem
yeah so we have traded for try uh tried
this for
this poisson problem and we also tried
a fluid flow problem
so which is basically
used it for burgers equation where
the input is the initial conditions and
the output is the full field
in that case
uh the problem was no longer just unit
we had
both fully connected layers
uh as well as convolution layers right
so in that case how to do the transfer
learning becomes kind of tricky because
uh it's it's not fully convolutional
like unit so we have tried this in other
cases also and we have seen similar
results that is by doing this transfer
learning using multi-grid
uh we saw speed up in uh and training
times
and almost at the same scale like we
could show
five 10x
speed up in training once you
start using a lower resolution
train network on higher resolution we
could show things better
okay sounds good um then why it asked we
can put adder
bars on
fvm simulations although we don't do it
every day can you put error bars on your
ml models and this is essential for
adopt
adoptions by real engineers
uh
i think for
absolutely so for error bars and ml
models would be how do they compare with
fem that would be the right error bars
and that's where we need certain
benchmarks saying okay if this is an ml
model for this problem
this is the best we see in fem
and how does it compare with that fm
simulation so
in my mind the baseline would still be a
traditional solver
and any ml model error bar would have to
be relative to that right and
and i completely agree we need error
bars and ml models and that will help in
adoption for
real engineers
yeah
okay so there's uh
george's um he he has a comment on the
um
about the memory issue so
he said uh unified shared memory is
already available in nvidia gpus since
cuda 6
he shared the link and it works like a
page swapping across this cpu gpu memory
boundary so i guess you you want to
check that out um yeah thank you thank
you very much
uh by the way do you have a access to
the chat room
i can see the chat window here oh
awesome okay well then
you will have a link
right there
okay sounds good
any other question from audiences
about the continuous integrations um
yeah i mean that's a big challenge um
you know we have to resolve i totally
agree with that and the main probably
uh
the reason why that's a challenge is the
reproducibility of the neural network
um as well so if you can elaborate more
on that aspect that would be wonderful
yeah so um
when it comes to deployability
there are challenges coming from the
machine learning world i mean even
within the traditional ml world
this deployability is a huge problem and
a lot of
uh
problems still stay in the prototype
phase and never reach production that's
because the the language gap it so for
example when it comes to ml
how do you what is deployment actually
means is it an application or is it an
api that somebody can integrate and how
does it work is is is one problem
and
you're absolutely right you know so that
is
when it comes to
[Music]
the the ciaml related problems it is the
matter of um both reproducibility that
is uh given uh
given a new input parameter let's say
i've trained a network
with a whole bunch of material
properties and i know that model work
should work very well for
a new metal property
then can i rely on that new network to
give me a solution is a matter of
the data in which it was trained on
right so what is the data distribution
that it was initially trained on is
going to be the main question
because any new uh input that you give
should be in that distribution for
giving uh giving the right solution
right that is number one that is
uh is the date is your model going to
drift
uh
from the
uh from the trained model
and if so
we need to let the user know that okay
this model is no longer doing very well
and
go back to your traditional solver for
this case right so there should be this
kind of transparency in terms of
the uh
of this model performance that is we
need to be very clear to say okay these
models work for these cases and we are
going to give you some error bounds on
how they work
and if this error bound is not suitable
for you go for another method right so
we see these ml models to be uh as
another tool in the toolkit for the for
the engineers who are designing these
things
and not the only two that way they can
compare and contrast they have the same
error bounce and error mechanism that
they can
evaluate any other new method right and
use along with their existing tools
so a lot of different dimensions that we
can think through when it comes to
uh deployability
what errors is definitely one big thing
okay sounds good okay uh there's a
not a not a question but the comment
from rob um he said it's not it's not
too difficult to put a pie torture torch
script model inside the c plus plus code
no
it's not difficult to put a
well rob he has a he he has worked on it
uh in the past
i mean you said it's not too difficult i
i don't know it's a
somewhat
uh yeah it becomes
if you want to do yeah we can add a word
offline
if you want to do training it becomes
non-trivial if you want to do
inferencing going from pi dots to c plus
plus is is fine
uh it depends on how we're going from
from one to the other
um and it if the question is is it can
this solve the deployment problem
i don't know i mean uh
a lot of systems are already set up
right so going into c plus code maybe a
starting point might not solve the
hundred percent of the
integration problems
so um
so yeah that's my my commenter for that
question if there was any all right
sounds good is there any other questions
and yeah the technical questions
then i would like to give a um you know
the path the chance of
thank you yeah
and and and thank you
the
talk and i just want to be clear no no
issues with with the technical content
of your talk i mean i i'm i'm happy to
see you making progress on these issues
and they're all important problems the
points i raised early in your talk
were about terminology and
and uh the scoping of the problem you
seem to be talking about this as those
for physics rather than other fields of
science you were seemed to be assuming
that we had to be working with large
data sets rather than small data sets
even though there's been
lots of work in machine learning on
small data sets and you seem to be
focusing
on neural nets even though
neural nets are are only one of the many
paradigms in machine learning and um and
and so i just wanted to encourage you uh
to use language that was more inclusive
that uh that acknowledged that machine
learning is a broad field uh that it can
be applied to many different sciences
not just physics and uh and
and also to use consider
reconsider the term scientific machine
learning because it suggests that it's
broader than what you seem to mean
that is
uh i do not take it that you are working
on
discovering new scientific laws from
actual data but rather
making existing models more efficient
that's fine that's that's that's an
important problem but scientific machine
learning suggests that it covers
everything and we have other terms for
fields like computational scientific
discovery
that i think are are more narrower and
more focused
so that's just my suggestions
absolutely so pat you you actually
did a nail it that's one of the
challenges that i'm talking about as the
first point
we being in the community
we have some at least some overlap
there is a problem with terminology
between what
we work on and what you work on and i
think
that's where i want to kind of make this
point that even with people who are
working in this space we are unable to
agree on terminology i'm sure right and
imagine so when we go talk to folks they
have no idea right when i say hello
right people are very smart but if we
are not able to agree on our terminology
how are we going to get more people into
this right how are we going to make this
more ubiquitous i think there is an
opportunity here that's what i'm trying
to bring in it we have an opportunity to
create certain terminology that where
when we're talking about problems we're
talking about
specific problems that the other person
knows okay they're working on this and
i'm happy to chat with you offline
because i think there's a problem that
needs to be
part part of part of where i'm coming
from
is that you know i've been working on
on using ai and machine learning methods
to discover scientific laws for over 40
years okay
and it's recently become a popular topic
again uh and and i'm and i'm pleased
that people are rediscovering some of
our old work but but i remember working
on this for a long time and saying well
what's this this field called
computational science uh which because i
thought i was doing computational
science but no uh computational science
was narrowly defined to be pde models
and getting them to run efficiently on
on high performance computers and i felt
locked out because because the
the computation basically people who
were doing com computational pdes were
had had had had taken this term
it sounded very broad term it actually
had a very narrow meaning and so i just
encourage people to use terms that
reflect the breadth of what they're
focusing on and not try and own the the
territory if you see the same kind of
thing all over ai for example graphical
models
there are a lot of graphical models that
aren't don't count as graphical models
and i think that's unfair
right right right and i resonate with
that and maybe i'll chat with you
offline and this is exactly one thing i
think we can solve as a community at
least i think have motivated folks here
and want to bring that thing into the
mainstream so that i'm like for example
myself i'm not familiar with your work
but
we could bring that as saying hey let's
figure the terminology first and
make whatever work fit into this and if
you want to add more we can have right
so i think there's an opportunity for us
to work here i'll be happy to talk with
you offline thank you for for being so
open to this thanks thanks man
wonderful uh well that is very
productive and
although um you know the community we
gathered in this webinar series
is it's not representing all the
communities in scientific computing or
scientific machine learning but it's a i
guess it's a definitely a starting point
i'm talking about the
clearing the terminology here
all right
um any other questions
or any other things you want to discuss
before you add john
[Music]
if not let's thank our speaker sanjay
for the wonderful talk and uh um yeah
and thank you everyone to join the ddps
seminar uh next one is actually the next
week so
um
after short period of time we'll see you
again
okay thank you everyone thank you santi
thank you thanks thanks for watching